all right but last and certainly not
least is the final store mandarake yep
it's brand new i i think we tried to go
to mandaraki last year we just didn't
have enough time to get yeah this year
we finally got it it is an absolute
[ __ ] smorgasbord of just random [ __ ]
shimorgas board of random [ __ ] in there
yeah i was like really excited to go to
mandaraki because like we always when we
go to akihabara or anywhere on mandarake
is we always got to hit up that store
because it's literally a lottery because
you never know what you can find you can
find some of the coolest [ __ ] and then
sometimes you go on the [ __ ] you go
there and you find some of the dumber
[ __ ] right so it was like how did you
guys feel going into mandarake do you
feel like you had enough budget uh i had
more than enough budget in fact i had to
make sure i got as close to three three
three three as possible in mandaraki
which is like [ __ ] impossible yeah i
have like 500 bucks left yeah oh really
yeah i had like nothing left i had like
500 bucks just to meet the criteria i
mean you did spend a [ __ ] on it i had to
go to amy i mean actually take stuff out
oh that i could was able to spend five
hundred dollars at mondragon oh sure
okay i still wanted to get quite a lot
of figures yeah yeah uh let's go uh what
was it so we had one challenge for
monday yeah mine was to buy a figure
from a show that you'd all watched mine
was to buy a fate figure that gantt
hasn't pulled for
oh
uh mine was to
uh ask the store clerk for an
recommendation recommendation
um yeah i'm just gonna lose a point
right away
[Laughter]
do you have i'm not gonna lie i totally
forgot that we were doing duplicate
characters i thought it was only
duplicate figures
no no no that's extra extra we've
learned the hard way about duplicate
characters and figures how many points
have you lost well i i lost two points
now yeah he has because he has four
deaths so i've lost him wait does he
have four dios yeah he bought three at a
stop yeah does does the deal in uh
does theo and jonathan one count yeah
that's still d all right would it count
i mean it's like a duo i don't know no
no no dio's there
zeo is clearly there
it's not like the spirit of dion so i've
lost a total of two points because of my
do buying obsessions
well the reason i actually bought this
one was because i wanted to get as close
as possible uh to the uh number and this
is one of them that i chose again i
totally forgot about um the the
duplicate the duplicate thing yeah yeah
yeah i ended up buying this but i mean
there's a lot to keep track of but i
also got very very close to the uh 333
okay nice nice all right so my one uh
was that i had to buy a fgo character
that got doesn't have on fgo now uh
i'm not gonna lie it's been way too long
since uh i played fgo myself
yeah so
tell me your thought process on this
because like my thought process was okay
i knew all of the basic characters that
you get at fgr yeah like the ones that
are just like guaranteed so those were
cl obviously out of the window yeah okay
i thought all right i i talked about it
with nabi my cameraman yeah who's like
an fgo expert and we basically made it
yeah we we basically like did a
hypothesis on what might he not have i
feel like you were really lucky getting
nubby as a cameraman because if conor
got it yeah he would have been he would
be [ __ ]
he would have just had to pick the fake
character yeah so i i had the choice
because i wanted to get as close to
three through three as possible yeah i
had the choice to either buy a shitload
of fake nendoroids
and just hope just hope that you don't
have one of them right or
i just go big and go hard on one figure
to get as close as possible i hope you
went big and went harder i went big and
went higher okay what did you get
so
i have i have a backup so i i bought two
feet ones okay okay so the first one i
bought because i'm not too confident
right do you have
ishtar
i got spaceshi
no archer archer ishta do you have
archer ishtar ah so you have the
character ishtar i'd say you have ishtar
it's it's it's different it's like the
goku black [ __ ] again no no no no no no
no no no
it's very different in fgo it's very
different okay yeah but that's okay
that's okay you can think about that
because i have another one okay
do you have
gray
no yes let's go
hell yeah navi oh my god okay because
this was the big gamble for me because i
was like i found gray in the [ __ ]
corner like the back corner [ __ ] is that
what is he what is he the grey's like
the like a grim reaper uh what what
class is it
uh zap rails airplane i think no i think
she's uh i have to check i see but yeah
i think it's a saber it's a saber i
think it's a [ __ ] you now
yeah i did not know
wait wait is gray released on
us fake go servers
yeah the event came out recently oh okay
oh no god sorry i mean i i wouldn't have
pulled for gray anyway
so so i saw this and i looked at na'bi
and i was like this is a recent
character isn't it he was like yes and
i'm like
he hasn't been playing that heavily
recently so there might be a chance but
i was so scared because this cost 160
dollars right so i was like i have to go
like all balls no brain on this can we
get this out of the box can uh yeah
let's get this out of the box because
this is actually a really nice feature
oh assassin okay
okay but that's i mean great gray is not
even from like the mainline fate series
no no
who is from the me i know i don't want
to know that
here we go
give me your [ __ ] i secured the point
i secured the point add a point on to me
baby all right i had a po i had a point
on for joey he deserves although yeah
although he had like the biggest cheat
sheet of all time ima imagine having
nabi as a cheat sheet for for that for
that challenge yeah what would you have
done if you got that challenge corner i
bought a saber figure or something
do you own saber
i actually don't not the main light
safer oh really yeah yeah oh wow
the the only good character from fate is
uh alexander the the greater alexander
yeah
in terms of designs i really like ishtar
so that's why
also ishtar is like a rin face so i'm
just like any time there's a rin face
for sale i know i know you like it yeah
i don't want to get in the face
that's okay that's okay you know you
please buy another dio figure go go go
go go go watch your fingers if you like
okay all right okay okay not dios though
show us one of yours um so first thing i
bought was a nico robin one this was
this was the recommended one from the
store clerk oh really
because you could have recommended a
little more expensive
i mean i i did tell him i did tell him
you know price price is an issue and he
was just like um so you asked the store
clerk for a recommendation what does he
recommend he goes do you like one piece
and i'm just like okay you're doing
you're doing yours you're like a pleb
yeah i'm like i guess you're just doing
your job
literally picked the least like
inoffensive
franchise you could go for at least he
picked like you know post time skip
robin right at least it's really pretty
skip robin
well like
you know you know about that right very
much but like about do you know that
this is skipper i don't know anything
don't spoil it for me i'm going to read
it
the funny thing is uh so this was like
one of the first figures i got at the
store
um so obviously with with a random guy
asking him asking him for a
recommendation you know i get it as a
store clerk you don't want to you don't
want to go crazy yeah you don't want to
seem too weird yeah you know you don't
want to seem too weird like when you uh
ask the waiter for a wine recommendation
he you know you know if he uh you know
offers you the most expensive oh wait
i've got to go he's not going to go for
like the fancy no he's going to go for
like
yeah yeah yeah um so afterwards uh at
the end when i had to like buy another
figure uh his station was actually next
to the hentai figure section
of course
and i'm sure sydney was frothing at the
mouth yeah and when he saw us uh when he
saw
that uh
when he saw that hentai figures were an
option yeah and that sydney was like
choosing a hentai figure he was just
like oh those were options
i could have picked one of those
oh why didn't you tell me instead you
went for literally the plebies
if you ask a staff for recommendation
he's like yeah the one with absolutely
gargantuan tits and like vagina he's
you're going to be like uh what yeah
because i will say out of all the
one-piece figures he did like he did
like pick the most cultured one he
possibly could that is true robin is
probably the most voluptuous one yeah
it's just a normal looking one-piece
figure yeah it doesn't look like
anything exceptional
i mean compared to like getting like one
of the male characters yeah
you know if it was like a standard zorro
or like sanji character then it would
have been like i like wrong there's like
a mcdonald's toy
dude i'd go to mcdonald's every day
did you give me if we got this for happy
meal
i'd be very happy
i'd be like mom we're getting mcdonald's
once again
here's the great figure right here okay
that's a big ass scythe look at that so
i've only seen grey in like lord el
malloy's case files um which i believe
is the spin-off oh that sounds pretty
sick yeah yeah it's very cool it's
visually appealing yeah yeah i'm pretty
happy with it and god doesn't have it
it's another saber face it's another
savior yet another saber face how do i
get this [ __ ] plastic off
you just have to rip the plastic oh
never mind there we go well all right i
will say i am glad that you didn't buy a
saber figure yeah because i bought a
saber figure really wait connor you
bought a fade figure
wait hold on a second hold the phone
does that mean you guys lose the point
because he has the beast
hold up for us hold up a second
bro
oh ashley you okay actually okay
um so i didn't know this but apparently
he definitely did pick a culture duh
what the [ __ ] should wears a g-string
oh now we all know who my favorite
one-piece character is
goddamn okay all right robin i see you i
don't remember that in the uh anime
okay hold on a second question time
you bought a saber
you have the big saber you bought a
russian bun does that count
nah
i don't know what what do you think
connor i thought you you bought uh a
sabre of the [ __ ] or something i don't
know
it's literally the exact same thing it
is actually
broke off oh [ __ ] i just don't break off
where did this come from what have you
done what you've done to your fate
figure i don't know oh he already
actually just broke oh my god i think
you lose a point just for that to be
honest
i mean it doesn't matter because you
both bought sabers so you lose a point
all right
so take a point off why did you buy a
sabre gone what did you do you didn't
think he was going to buy sable
i didn't think you didn't think i was
going to buy a fate yeah that's why
that's why i was that's why when i got
the [ __ ] like buy a fate character
that god doesn't have i was sweating my
ass off because i'm like i'm definitely
going to lose a point because he's
probably bought all the [ __ ] fake
characters
okay wait where did i put this how do i
mount this
just on that right no
if you want to figure this out for me
that'd be great please give me the stuff
uh yeah so actually you know i have
watched fate as much as i mean that i
hate it i i just hate it because ghant
talks about it so god damn much wait
this should be a like a stand
like a long thing uh maybe it's in the
box or something i don't know well
that's that's a good saber figure
actually actually yeah this broke off
one of the things i don't know why it's
very flimsy oh it's it's it's oh it's a
little end here yeah i mean i mean uh if
you weren't careful with that which uh
you definitely weren't gonna look
careful with it yeah maybe let's not
forget
another point oh my god i'm losing so
many points
connor's like kind of gaining points and
then just losing them just as quickly
did you guys did you take a point off
guanine corner yeah okay all right so
that that's actually a good fate for you
i like the ones that are really nice
that is a very nice saving figure i
think it wasn't that i'll give i'll give
you that one i'll give it
god um nothing but fate here look at
that it's god's dreamland right here i
know right
gray and saber
wait i woke up in a podcast where people
bought face uh fate figures and none of
them were bored by me what the [ __ ]
going on how much do you think this cost
this one yeah
it's about 200 right 100 bucks oh wow
wow that'd be good for 100 bucks yeah
not bad at all yeah so yeah like i said
i mean on the whole fake [ __ ] but i like
re-zero
i like i like unlimited blade works and
i like fake zero should watch heaven's
feel as well
you're here
no no no me you've literally ruined fate
for me i actually can't watch it
all right uh what else did you guys buy
oh how many more i've got one more
i know what you've got left i saw you
[ __ ] ask for it